bonjour à vous que c'est curieux
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de ça et
oui figurez vous qu'il ya des
scientifiques qui font la même chose que
dans notre générique mais en vrai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
évidemment il ne s'agit pas de pelé la
terre pour en faire des tests mais pour
voir ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur et ça
ressemble à ça oui ce n'est pas
forcément évident à première vue mais ce
que vous venez de voir est une planète
virtuelle semblable à la terre
réalisée par des chercheurs de
l'observatoire de lyon et de
l'université de sydney oui aujourd'hui
on va parler de géologie et plus
exactement de tectonique des plaques
avec des planètes virtuelles et pour
ceux qui suivent c'est un sujet qui me
tient particulièrement à coeur
shih tzu bon revenons depuis le début si
je vous dit tectoniques ça vous parle
[Musique]
bon en fait pour les géologues la
tecktonik c'est pas tout à fait ça la
surface de la terre est divisé en grands
morceaux que l'on appelle des plaques
tectoniques sur certaines il peut y
avoir des continents mais pas sur tout
d'autres ne sont composés que d'océan
ces plaques se déforme peu et vont
bouger les unes par rapport aux autres
95 % de la surface de la terre est
recouverte par de très grandes plaques
tectoniques comme par exemple la plaque
eurasienne où je me trouve actuellement
mais il y en a d'autres qui sont
beaucoup plus petites comme la plaque
ibérique où il n'y a que le portugal et
l'espagne
mais c'est sûr qu'à l'échelle humaine ça
reste grand en fait c'est un peu comme
si la surface de la terre était un
puzzle avec deux tailles de pièces très
différentes et les chercheurs se sont
demandés pourquoi et depuis quand cette
différence de taille exister le problème
quand on étudie la surface terrestre
c'est que plus on remonte dans le temps
- on a accès aux différentes pièces du
puzzle
en fait on peut voir la terre comme un
énorme système de recyclage
lorsque les plaques tectoniques
vieillissent et se refroidisse elle
plonge sous la surface
c'est la subduction on a donc deux
problèmes le premier c'est que pour
comprendre pourquoi tout ça bouge
il faudrait pouvoir regarder les
mouvements à l'intérieur de la terre ce
qui est un petit peu compliqué et le
deuxième problème c'est que les plaques
disparaissent au fur et à mesure du
temps l'idée est de pouvoir étudier
l'évolution des plaques
tout en sachant exactement ce qu'il se
passe sous la surface
malin ces images représentent
l'évolution au cours du temps de la
convection
c'est à dire les mouvements les
écoulements de ma chaudes et froides
dans les 3000 premiers kilomètres de
roche sous nos pieds à ce stade certains
auront ticket oui je vous parle
d'écoulement de roche
en fait c'est comme les glaciers il faut
juste se placer à la bonne échelle de
temps et ici les chaînes le temps c'est
la dizaine de millions d'années donc les
roches ça c'est cool et ça c'est cool à
la surface de leur planète virtuelle
les chercheurs ont pu délimiter des
plaques et ils ont remarqué après
plusieurs centaines de millions d'années
la formation de deux types de plaques
bien distincts des grandes et des
petites comme sur terre et ils ont
comparé sa avec les mouvements qui ont
lieu à l'intérieur de leur planète
virtuelle les grandes plaques vont
suivre les grands mouvements de
convection et aux endroits où elle s'en
fout ce la surface terrestre est soumise
à de fortes contraintes et elle va se
fragmenter en petites plaques
un peu comme quand on découpe un brownie
en surface ça fait une flopée de petits
morceaux qui se distribuent autour du
morceaux découpés
voilà donc grâce à cette recherche on en
sait un peu plus sur la surface de la
terre et sur son évolution lors de la
formation de super continent voilà cet
épisode très terre-à-terre est terminée
donc voilà bien garder les pieds sur
terre ok c'est le moment de me taire
[Musique]